anthony hopkins who's done pretty damn
well for himself especially this year
said the minute i put on the wardrobe
the character just unfolds
emma's alexandra byrne had the challenge
of designing costumes for a film set in
the early 19th century
to meet that challenge she looked at
everything paintings journals
and even in museums to prepare for
mourinho's black bottom
costume designer anne roth reads the
script and asks herself
questions about the character like when
she goes to bed where are those clothes
do they fall on the floor does she hang
them up from there anne builds the
costumes which define the character
for mank trish somerville used sears and
roebuck catalogs
charlie chaplin movies and still
photographs from the 20s 30s and 40s
to create an authentic look of real
people from movie history
being a daigler spent three weeks in
china researching costumes for mulan
she said her goal was to enable the
audience to grasp something essential
about the character
in the case of mulan herself she used
color and costume to convey
an uplifting and positive message
pinocchio's costume designer
massimo cantini parini also is a strong
believer that color helps create the
character
and because red is the color that
expresses powerful emotions like anger
passion love and lying pinocchio became
the only character in the movie wearing
red
and the oscar goes to
anne roth my rainey's black body
the academy congratulates anne roth and
accepts the oscar on her behalf
thank you